- Now this is incredible.
I've literally not
seen a calculator.
(man laughing)
- You haven't?
- I've not seen an actual
calculator in a long time.
Look at this rare item.
- [Man] That's a
graphing calculator.
- Yeah, it is.
- I feel like I
can sell this on eBay.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("And The Homies Say"
by Don Solo)
- College is
fundamentally finished.
It's gonna take
forty years, here's why.
Your parents cared.
You even care,
'cause you grew up to
care, but your kids won't,
and that'll be it.
Your kids will not force
their kids to go to college.
Game over.
Because your the
first generation,
your friends are
that really
struggled with the notion
of why do I have
to stand for reality
what it gave me at scale.
Like everyone feels it,
other than the poor shit ones
whose parents pay for it.
So, back to my point,
like everything's in trouble
because of the internet,
everything we've got forward.
- Yeah, it was really bizarre
that I've had a job where
like I've read books by the
CEO and follow him on Twitter
and like so that's really cool.
I watched the thing
you did with John Legend
last week, that
was really awesome.
- [Gary] Yeah, that was fun.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] It was cool
for you especially, right?
- Oh yeah, definitely.
- [Gary] Real pleasure,
I'm glad you're here.
- Yeah, appreciate it, man.
- Talk to ya.
- Hey!
- Hey.
- Did you envision
this life for yourself
when you made that
first video, like did you know
it was going to
blow up, and just...
- [Gary] I knew that it
was going to work,
but I never thought it
was going to lead to this,
and what I mean by that is not,
I mean, I probably thought
it was going to be bigger,
I thought I would be bigger.
It's not that I'm like
"Oh my God, how'd this happen?"
Like I've always
kind of known, you know,
even when you're a kid,
you know your personality,
if you pay attention, you know
your personality type, right?
Like every time
I was in a new setting,
people reacted to me in
big way, like infatuated,
I wanna be your
best friend or like, eww,
I don't like that, you know.
So I've always
known I've got a style
that definitely,
like, creates energy,
and especially like
when I was 13, 14, 15,
when everybody
tries to be chill,
and I was like too much,
and it was annoying
and this and that, so,
I always believe in myself.
But you never
know how it manifests.
Like, if you told me
what's gonna happen in 10 years,
I would tell you that it's
going to be way, way, way big,
but I have no idea what.
I have no idea, other
than as many people on Earth
as I possibly can help
it will know about it,
and I'll enjoy doing it
and I'll be fully into it,
and I'm going to
try to break something
that's the establishment.
That's my truth.
I want to break the
establishment,
'cause the establishment
is vulnerable and
I love the competition of that.
("And The Homies Say"
by Don Solo)
- [Man 2] Okay, very simple,
we'll run through it.
Joe's gonna do an intro--
- Let's do it, I'm--
- [Man 2] Questions, we'll go.
- I'm good to go.
- [Joe] Cool, so,
definitely excited
to have GaryVee here for,
what is this,
the 34th?
- [Man 2] 34th episode.
- I think a lot of
people speak the truth.
I think there's not
a lot of people who are
hardcore, hardcore
operators who speak the truth.
I think there's a
lot of voices out there
who are speaking the truth,
they just don't
have the experience.
Like I'm grossly underrated
because of my own narrative,
meaning the way
I narrate myself.
I'm a do-er!
Like, I'm in meetings.
Like I just
walked from a company,
an office-wide meeting,
and like five, and
11, and seven meetings
with employees.
Like I'm doing!
And I think, you know,
I notice,
like I'm not as sharp,
like for example,
I'm not buying wine right now.
I can talk about
buying and selling product
'cause I did it every
day of my life for 15 years.
Am I as sharp at talking about
buying and selling products
as I was six years ago?
No!
'Cause I'm not
actively doing it.
- [Joe] Right.
- And so, I think that one thing
that everybody who's
listening should think about is
really audit who
you're paying attention to.
I don't, you know,
I think people
think I tell it like it is
because I curse
and do it aggressively
and I think it
gives a narrative of that.
But I think a
lot of people do that
that are
completely full of shit.
I think what is
resonating with people
is I've got answers.
Like the reason
I do Q&amp;A all the time
is 'cause I know the answer.
'Cause I'm doing it.
And I think
that's super interesting
and I think more of us,
Millennials in the workforce.
So, for one example,
I'm a huge Millennial advocate
because I hate the narratives
that are painted on Millennials
like I know
unlimited Millennials
that want to make lots of
money and work their asses off.
- [Joe] Right.
- What I think Millennials,
so that's where old people
are wrong about Millennials,
but where Millennials are wrong
is experience matters.
When I was a Millennial,
A.K.A. when I was in my 20s,
I was ridiculously talented.
I went on to become a
very successful businessman.
I was right about my bravado.
Here's the problem.
41-year-old Gary
thrashes 24-year-old Gary.
17 years of experience is real.
So, old people, me,
40-year-olds and above,
need to stop talking
shit about Millennials
but Millennials need to start
putting value on experience
because the smartest Millennials
that are walking into my room
telling me how
to run my business
with zero context
of ever doing it,
is laughable at best
and obnoxious at worst.
- [Man 2] Patience
and perseverance
is what you always
advocate for from Millennials.
- And for everybody,
even for 41-year-olds, right.
I think I live and eat patience!
- [Man 2] Yep.
- I've got everything
in front of me.
I can cash it in right now.
Like I can take a
$100 million off the
table right now.
And if you think about
what $100 million is,
right, like, what $57 million
in post-tax money is,
that's generational
wealth, right.
That is like
I will never spend it all.
I'll probably,
just by investing into Facebook,
you know, like,
and in Netflix and Amazon.
Or the market.
Taking $25 million,
putting it in the market,
never thinking about it again.
As long as America doesn't melt,
I am like I'll
have $100 million
when I'm 70.
Like I'm set!
But I want to buy
the New York Jets.
I want to have
an all time legacy,
so I practice patience.
Patience is a
mapping to your ambition.
If your ambition is
to live on, you know,
a thousand dollars a year
in Peru, you know,
well then you
can quit right now.
You don't need to be patient.
Like cash in,
cash in all your
chips and move, right.
So I think patience
is a complete correlation
to your ambition.
I think the reason I am who I am
is because I was born to be
the biggest showman bullshit
of bullshit of all time.
Born to be it!
And my father,
I give my mother so much credit.
My father sucked it out of me
at an early enough stage
that it became my truth.
And so I have the
pizzazz and ability to get you
but then I deliver on
something more noble then.
And that's why I think
a lot of people viscerally
when they first see me
are like, "Hmmm".
Right? 'Cause I have it!
And then it
takes time to be like,
"Oh wait a minute" right?
- [Joe] No this
has been fantastic,
that you for coming.
- Thanks for having me guys.
- [Joe] It's always
good to have you.
- Thank you.
Awesome, thanks guys.
- [Man 2] Alright, thanks Gary.
You the man!
- Thanks man.
- [Joe] Appreciate it.
- My pleasure, thank you.
- Similar to the
interview you guys just did
with the Ambition podcast,
give the folks watching this
for the maybe the one person
that hasn't heard your spiel,
doesn't know your background.
Give a little bit of background
before we jump into talking
about sales and marketing
and all that.
- Before I do that,
I'm always fascinated
by people's actions
and how quickly
you can get insight.
The fact that you gave
that podcast a
shout out in the intro
to your entire conference,
speaks obnoxious volumes of
how you think about the world.
And literally puts me
in a really good mood.
Good for you
and probably a
tremendous lesson.
You want to
talk about alignment?
Like doing
right by the universe.
Doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
Like, genuinely
this is not a joke
and I know I'm (laughs)
just very weird
start to a podcast
or a conference.
It's unbelievable
to me how much more
I want to now give to you
because of the subtlest,
littlest thing you just did.
- [Man 3] Can you
talk to us about how
the Vayner marketing team
and the Vayner sales team
have collaborated
to win those accounts?
- Sales and marketing
orgs are gonna hate each other
because they have
different objectives,
and I am empathetic to both.
Let me explain.
Sales people, I'm a
salesman, sales people,
one move that your
marketing team can do
can change everything for you.
They can go 0 for 92, they
can be the biggest shlameals,
you can hate them, and one
activation at a conference,
one video they
make for Facebook,
one thing, one sponsorship,
one thing fixes everything.
They are literally Mike Tyson.
Right?
One punch, and that
you have to respect.
There's nothing you,
salesperson, can do
that will ever map to
one excellent execution
in marketing that
has the same impact.
Next, marketers,
you're full of shit,
and you're fluffy,
and most of the stuff
you're gonna do doesn't matter,
and you're high brow,
and fuck your degrees,
and I don't give
a shit what awards
or what articles are written
about how clever you are,
you are not as practical,
you are not in day to day,
you are the offensive
superstar of a football team,
but probably more
like a wide receiver
'cause the
CEO's the quarterback,
so I love that you can
be highly successful,
and I love that
everybody knows who you are,
but just like wide
receivers in the NFL,
you're a primadonna.
You're not practical.
You don't get the
full picture all the time,
and your sales people,
A.K.A. the offensive line,
is there day in
and day out, grinding,
trying to clean up
for mistakes you've made,
or misses you've had.
They don't have the
luxury of your budget
that has no quantifiable
evidence to success,
and you've gotta be
empathetic to your sales team
because they're there
and there's no wiggle room.
Your sales team
can't say to the CEO,
and more importantly, the CFO,
"Well the long-term
impact of that conversation"
"I have will do this."
Even though it's true.
Even though I am
a great sales person
because I set up sales,
and I'll have a sales call
that's actually not
even about the sales call,
it's about what I'm gonna
try to do with that person
in a year, but I'm
only justifying to myself.
As a sales person
wearing that jersey,
you've gotta make sales,
and everybody's just
looking at your numbers.
Nobody's giving you
any credit for the set up.
Marketing person, you're only
getting credit for the set up.
Both of you need to
desperately deploy empathy
to the other party, and that's
the organizations that win,
but that's up to the head of
marketing and the head of sales
for her and him to
be aligned at the top,
and create the air
cover for those 83 employees,
or two employees, to be able
to create that cohesive unit
and that's what
great coaching is.
To get your offensive
and defensive coordinator
completely aligned to
create a cohesive unit
and most people
are not good at it.
- [Man 3] Gary, You've gotta
get to your next meeting.
- Yes.
- [Man 3] Close with this:
Tupac or Biggie?
- Biggie.
- [Man 3] Alright.
Thank you so much
- B, I, double G, I.
(group laughter)
- That was for you.
Thank you so much.
- Awesome, man.
- [Man 3] I really appreciate it.
- My pleasure. Thanks, guys.
("In the Springtime"
by Don Solo)
Good to go?
Awesome, great.
Morning, everybody!
Here in Chattanooga, Tennessee,
we're gonna go
through a case study.
("Like This" by Justin Stone)
What I'm hoping is
that (censored)
inspires everybody to
make scenes from sitcoms,
to make documentaries,
to make music videos,
to make things that don't
look like a commercial, right?
I mean, I think if and when
you watch the three of them,
the other two clearly
have commercial DNA,
where as obviously
(censored) does not,
and I fundamentally,
pot-committed believe
that that is the
creative that is gonna work.
I mean, that's
what people share.
People aren't
gonna share a commercial.
There's not a single person.
That's super important.
So, no, I don't
have too much to add.
("Like This" by Justin Stone)
- [Man 4] What's up man?
- How are you guys?
- [Man 4] I just
wanted to say hi.
- How are you?
- I know you guys are busy.
We just walked by here.
- [Man 4] We need
you to come eat here,
but it looks like your
already busy with that.
- Awesome man. Real pleasure.
How are you guys?
- Absolutely great to meet you.
- Good, man.
Nice to meet you.
- I've waved at you
but you were eating.
I didn't mean to.
- [Gary] No worries, no worries.
- We were very
excited to meet you.
- Thank you,
thank you real pleasure.
- Actually we met
DRock earlier too.
- Awesome, man, thank you.
Nice meeting you guys.
- This man brought me right
into his startup company.
(inaudible)
All the things that you said.
- I made him
read all your books.
We watch DailyVee
every single day.
- Do me need to
talk about it for a week?
(inaudible)
- [Gary] Get in here.
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
- [Man 5] Thanks
dude appreciate it.
- Thank you so much.
Continued success.
("Like This" by Justin Stone)
- [Man 6] Here's our CEO.
Ready?
He's in the closet.
- This is it. (laughs)
This is the way to do it.
- [Man 6] We ran out of space.
- This is great
executive action here.
- That's right.
- Exactly.
- Hey man Gary.
How are you?
- Yeah Jason Brovacha.
Nice to see you.
- Gary how's it going?
- How are you? Hi.
- [Amanda] Amanda.
- Amanda, Gary.
- Connie Stratton.
- How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- You've got the real spot.
- I've got the spot.
- [Gary] You've got the spot.
- [Connie] Yeah I do.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] They
hooked you up proper.
- [Connie] Yep they did.
They took care of
me putting me in here.
- [Gary] This is nice.
It's a nice little view.
- Yeah I get to see--
- This is you're right.
- I get to see people
standing out the windows.
- This is
literally literally how
Wine Library was built.
Like by the way,
this exact table.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] This exact table.
- See you went to Costco.
- [Gary] Yep.
And just like inner
in like we built a closet
like a couple years earlier
and that's where me
and my internet team sat.
And we had the
servers right in there.
Like...
- Nice.
- [Gary] Oh it was cool,
so cool. It's the best.
- We're grinding it out in here.
- [Gary] Now this is incredible.
I've literally
not seen a calculator.
- You haven't? (laughs)
- I've not seen an actual
calculator in a long time.
Look at this rare item.
- That's a graphing calculator.
- Yeah it is.
- I feel like I could
sell this on eBay.
You know what's
crazy about that spot?
This is the third
time this has happened.
That I've looked at that spot
and I always think
about Kennedy's assassination.
- [Man 6] Huh.
- I could see that.
- [DRock] Maybe the angle?
- [Gary] Just
something about like
I'm like there's
a grassy knoll.
And like there's a building.
Like I don't know.
Just like I'm in the south.
Like just my head goes
there every single time.
Oh by the way.
When I was in Dallas one time,
I had a little bit of
time before my airport.
And the guys like,
"You want to drive the path?"
I was like yeah.
It was really quite.
Not dark.
Just kind of like.
That whole thing
really captivated me as a kid.
I would say from like
fifth to like eleventh.
- [Man 7] As a history lesson?
- [Gary] Yeah.
From fifth to eleventh grade,
every time anything was about it
I would like,
I was so into it.
It captivated me.
- [Man 8] So you into the
conspiracy theories of it?
- [Gary] Oh for sure.
Like a hundred percent.
- Something happened.
Something else.
- A hundred percent.
("The Force" by Don Solo)
Good day so far in
Chattanooga, Tennessee.
Had some internal meetings.
Some external meetings.
That's it.
I like this character.
Uh oh bubbles.
Yo Gary beard.
What do you got going on today?
Not much regular Gary.
Just hustling.
("The Force" by Don Solo)
- Welcome, I'm Kaitlyn,
and I work for Dynamo.
And I'm here to
ask Gary some questions
that I've put together,
and then we're
gonna open the floor up
so you guys can ask questions.
- If I can bless you
with anything besides health,
it would be self-awareness.
Like it is the
ultimate, ultimate thing.
Like if you actually
know who the fuck you are,
shit gets weird
if you're really fully there
and I mean that.
Like, and somewhere, I don't
know if it was circumstantial,
but the immigrant thing,
or great parenting,
or mom and dad had sex
at the exact right moment,
and gave me the right DNA,
something around fourth grade,
everything became
very crystal clear,
which was oh shit,
this system that I'm
going through is not for me.
How many rings Saturn has,
or like, you know,
any other variable that
I'm gonna be taught here.
And this is before
I realized, or anybody realized,
that there would be an internet
that would completely
commoditize information, right?
This is not for me.
And so what was very hard for me
was when I was
getting D's and F's,
and my teachers
and my friends' parents
told me I was a loser.
That was hard.
Like you're still a kid,
as confident as I was,
people looking you
dead in the face and saying
you're not gonna amass to
anything, and really meaning it,
is challenging.
Or like,
literally, friends' parents,
you can see they were
disappointed that their friend
was friends with me
because they were
worried that I would rub off
because they're only KPI
was go to Harvard, right?
So, that was challenging.
But from the day I was free,
(claps) right?
I would tell you
that when you are doing
what you're supposed to do,
I don't believe in
like, the secret, or like,
I don't know how
zenned-out I am or not,
but I would be lying
to you, and to you guys,
like this is the
only thing I want.
I like the pain. Right?
Like so what's hard?
What's hard, and a
lot of you know this,
is when there's
nobody else to blame,
it's your fuckin' fault.
But I don't know how to
breathe in any other way.
I love the fact that
every single problem is mine.
I love that I'm actually
a firefighter, you know?
Every day, it's bad.
Like I'm nervous.
This is real.
There is an
underlining nervousness
running in the
background of me right now,
because I know I'm
gonna be zoned into this,
and when I'm done in 40 minutes,
I'm gonna take my phone out,
and it's highly likely
that there's some
shit that's fucked up.
Right?
But that is all I know.
That's all I've ever been.
That's all, you know, like,
I've always wanted
all the responsibility.
Having coach here, like
I wanna take the last shot.
And if I make it, I want
all the fuckin' accolades.
And if I miss it, I want
everybody to shit on me.
And so it's not been hard.
What's hard now
is praying that the
people I love are healthy
so that I don't get derailed
from doing what I love to do.
Like, knowing that this
is the prime of my career,
and it's so awesome,
and I can only hope
for the kind of health
that has been--
Like business is not hard to me
'cause it's what I do best.
Everything else is hard to me.
Like hanging a
fucking picture to me
is extremely hard.
Like ordering food, doing
anything logistics oriented.
Like, if you told me to book
my own flight home today,
I'd fuckin' crumble
like cheap chair.
But like, run a
$500 million business, like,
and deal with all the pressures,
that's my natural state.
- [Man 10] What do you
think about Alexa?
- I'm obsessed.
And I think that
voice saves time,
and time is the
ultimate arbitrage,
and that most of the things
I spend my time on right now,
brainstorming in my head,
are trying to figure out
how to be part of
the morning routine
that I'm convinced is
gonna be AI and voiced out.
That everybody's
gonna wake up and say,
"Alexa", or "Google Home",
or something else,
give me my morning routine.
I believe every one of us are
gonna listen to information
for the first 7 to 11 minutes
of our morning
while we brush our teeth.
And I'm dying to figure out
how to be one of
the voices of that.
Me, as Gary, as like your
daily business motivation,
and then me as a client.
So this is not a joke,
you're gonna love this,
and I love you for asking this,
'cause I'm so pot-committed,
I'm actually trying to
buy an umbrella company
or invest in one.
This is so weird, look at
how I'm thinking about this.
I want to buy or
start an umbrella company
just so I can
build an Alexa skill
and a Google Home skill
to be the brand that
provides you the weather
every morning.
Like I wanna build
the best weather app
for the voice world.
It's like
owning the first result
on Google search for weather.
- [Woman 2] Why do you
need the umbrella?
- That's just how I decided
I wanted to deploy it.
You don't.
That's my personal, like,
oh wouldn't it
be fun to build like
a $400 million umbrella business
on the back of arb'ing Alexa?
Because your weather is
brought to you by, like,
Umbee Umbrellas,
and like people would hear
that 400 trillion times a day.
Like, it's so fat.
I'm a big believer.
I believe in it the most.
- Thank you so much.
- Awesome. Thanks guys.
(audience applause)
Thanks for having me.
Good luck.
- If you had to
start a city to help
hundreds of millions
of people out of poverty
how would you go about it?
- If I had to
start a city to help
hundreds of millions
of people out of poverty
how would I go about it?
So like can we dig
into it a little bit?
- Sure.
- So (stammering)
I would think
about it in two ways.
Short term vs. long term.
- Okay.
- So my short term
answer is quite weird.
Which is I would
probably fundraise
against the top
.0001% of human beings
and try to take you
know how the trillionaires
are giving 99% of
their wealth away?
I think it's the
altruistic type thing
that you could convince
the Buffets and the Gates
and the characters of the world
to give you
disproportionate capital
that basically vigged
the financial elements
that you would
need for those people
and then bring them
in to that environment
and then give
them half and then make
them earn half and
then create some sort
of machine, right?
That would be what
I would do if I had
to do it in a 10 year window.
At a much
greater level I would try
to create the most
capitalistic environment
that like I always
think things that
are so challenging come
in pulling from opposites.
It's why I think America
has such strength, right?
It's such a complicated question
so I can't
answer it very quickly
but whatever it would look like
it would look like pulling
from opposite directions.
- Okay.
- Meaning how
do you build a city
that awards meritocracy
but takes care of the
people that naturally don't
have the DNA disposition
and I think that tension
in the U.S. has been very
successful for 300 years
and I think replicating
that with all the learnings
that didn't work
in the U.S. system,
maybe like the birth
child of like 80% U.S.,
10% Sweden, 10% China,
or maybe 70% U.S. actually,
70% U.S., 15 Sweden,
15 China feels
like the right place for me.
("Ready To Go" by Bazanji)
Okay so listen
I mean I'll be available for
the call whenever
we can all get on
but the answer is this,
this is what you need to know.
I'm not gonna...
We have the right
team my internal team,
we're not gonna like
if you spend a dollar
we'll it the best
way possible against
the reality of your business
and the reality of the Facebook
and influencers marketplace
so I feel very confident.
("Ready To Go" by Bazanji)
Yo man it's GaryVee.
What up my man?
Life good?
Hey listen
running to this meeting
but I had like one second.
I'm just so fired up that you
had context for
me and what I'm up to
like let's stay
in real touch man
you're like
literally on my list.
Like I made a list of nine guys
that I think
people are sleepin' on
and have it and not
listen they're not sleeping
on you you're on the radar but
I have a funny feeling
about you my man.
(laughing)
- My names Chris.
- I'm aware. Good to see you.
Good to see you. Pleasure.
- Monty.
- We're on the same team.
(laughter)
- Twins.
- We were on the
same flight last night.
- [Gary] Is that right?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Well you
should have said hello.
- Well, I didn't see you until
you were on your
way out the door.
- [Gary] Out. Got it. Got it.
Too many people always want to
justify their
short term behavior.
For having some
big macro vision.
Like, opportunity comes.
Like when you're right.
Historic like...
Being right about social media
made me famous let alone gave
me business opportunities.
I wasn't sitting around
six years ago being like
rappers and athletes are going
to want to be my
friend because of this.
You can't even think that way.
You just know that it's
right and you build on it.
- Yeah.
- E-sports is right.
Period. End of story.
("Ready To Go" by Bazanji)
Guys, quick fun fact.
I actually want you to do this.
Go to Oprah's
Instagram account right now
and go all the way down
and look at her
first Instagram photo ever.
I'm serious, do it right
now while Megan's talking.
I literally went
into a hotel room
and was like Oprah listen to me.
You...(laughter)
My mom loves this story.
Oprah, you have
to be on Instagram.
Uhh. I'm like you
have to be on Instagram.
She's like, "What do
I take a picture of?"
I'm like, me.
(group laughter)
The fact...the fact
that that is still there.
I screen shoot it
like every six months
I always think like eventually
she's just going
to just delete it.
I believe that
voice in the morning.
The first three to ten minutes
is kind of like the new
be the first result
on a Google search
for the next half decade.
And I think everybody
here who's doing marketing
whether you run a brand,
whether you've started a fund
and you want to
be in that world.
Penetrating peoples first
10 minutes that they listen to.
I think is going
to be big stakes.
Big money.
Because I believe
history just repeats itself.
If you look at the behavior
of when the alarm
clock radio came out
of how many of tens
of millions of Americans
had their alarm
go off and give them
the morning radio show
or the more like ten,
ten wins in New York.
Like giving them the
first eight to ten minutes
as they got ready.
Such an opportunity
if you're willing to
build a custom skill
and put your brand on it.
Levar Burton was the
first celebrity on Twitter.
- [Woman 3] For real.
- For real.
For real.
Like, before anybody came.
Before Ashton's competition
with CNN to get to a million.
Before MC Hammer who was early.
- Yeah.
- Before Chamillionaire
who was early.
(group laughter)
- Chamillionaire was early.
Levar Burton was like, yo I'm
here and everybody follow.
("Ready To Go" by Bazanji)